although sony is yet to officially
announce or detail a new entry in the
god of war series rumors have surfaced
suggesting god of war for may be based
on norse mythology i'm lucy and welcome
to your / him up gamespot news update on
equal fourth twitter user shinobi 602
who has a proven track record of leaking
accurate information on unannounced
games tweeted to the halls of valhalla
my boy hashtag God of War for in
response nerd leagues did some digging
and found its way to the website
belonging to former Sony Santa Monica
artist vinian McManus a private section
of the website contained artwork
featuring a character that looks similar
to series protagonist Kratos you can be
seen in various Norse mythology inspired
environment the nur nicht website has
now been taken down and empty archives
of the images are also being removed
sony has not officially announced a new
god of war yet these images may be
entirely unrelated or represents an idea
that it was exploring previously but may
not have been pursued the last entry in
the god of war series was ascension
which was released for the PlayStation 3
back in 2013 how do you think these
images are legit are you excited to
buddy up with crates us once again let
me know in the comments below or come
find me on Twitter I'm at least see
James games but more on god of war keep
it gamespot
[Music]